there's no doubt that avengers endgame
is going to be one of the most defining
flicks of 2019 from marketing efforts to
storytelling promises from the all-star
cast to the movie's title here other
things an endgame has already had to
right out of the park these days it's
almost impossible to avoid spoilers for
upcoming films and the bigger the movie
the worse it is from Robert Frane
spreading rumors to paparazzi crashing
film sets to leaks from within the
studio's themselves spoilers are
plastered across the internet in fact
too many movies these days spoil the
plot in their own trailers it can be a
real bummer for fans who want to be
surprised all of which makes a marketing
campaign for Avengers end games so
amazing not only as Marvel managed to
keep any real spoilers from slipping out
they also released several gripping
trailers and teasers that somehow
ratchet up the excitement without
actually telling us much of anything at
all even the name of the film itself was
a closely guarded secret until the first
teaser hit in December and even when
fans guessed something correctly Marvel
was great about well completely lying in
order to keep their secrets when
directly asked that the title of the
fourth Avengers film was spoken by a
character in Avengers infinity war
co-director Joe Russo offered uh
Patterson direct know sending fans in
another direction but that was a dang
waiy we're in the inking yeah well
played Marvel well played the complete
lack of information has actually helped
fuel excitement among fans and they've
been forced to make up their own
theories which have since been debated
endlessly online and the less they tell
us the more we want to know it's a
testament to the tremendous cliffhanger
Marvel left us with at the end of
Avengers infinity war ending one of the
biggest most anticipated films in
history with the good guys losing and
almost everyone dead was a massive risk
and this one has paid off in spades
since the beginning of the MCU Marvel
has put as much emphasis on fun as they
do on action 3
so shifting to the kind of downbeat
story that infinity war delivered and
endgame promises would seem like a
dramatic shift and it is emphasis on the
drama part one of the few constant
criticisms of the movies taking place in
the MCU has been that the story stakes
aren't high enough for instance in
Captain America Civil War the massive
battle between superheroes had only one
temporary casualty in the form of war
machine and by the end of the movie he
was back to cracking jokes are you Tony
dank yes this is this is Tony stank
you're in the right place thank you for
that luckily the Russo brothers do the
unavenged end game it needed something
more real because it needed to actually
matter to fans Anthony Russo declared
that unless you have real stakes is sort
of limited in terms of the emotional
impact a story can have on you what
we're looking for in storytelling or art
is emotional catharsis and that's not
simply getting what you want it's
getting an emotional experience that
makes you feel and respond to it and
energizes you on some level co-director
Joe Russo added that this is a fantasy
world and yes remarkable things can
happen in a fantasy world but they come
at an incredibly high cost right from
the start
Marvel has been upfront about its master
plan with its phase 1 films leading into
phase 2 films which led to its phase 3
films which led to Avengers endgame so
after 21 films and 11 years of buildup
it's fitting that endgame is poised to
tie together every corner of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
this process already began in infinity
war which brought together the
straightforward superhero world of the
Avengers with the cosmic action of the
guardians of the galaxy and the mystic
might of the sorcerer supreme Doctor
Strange and dense games seems like it'll
go even further with ant-man in the
quantum realm set to play a central role
in the fight against Thanos until now
even with two films under his belt it's
felt like ant-man has been on the
fringes of the MCU but with a little
less of engine tential II playing the
biggest parts Marvel has managed to do
the impossible
make a movie goers truly care about
nearly every character appearing in more
than 40 hours of films finally Avengers
endgame is already doing something right
simply by being what is now
implies an ending one of the big
problems of comic books or movie
franchises or TV shows is that the story
is a pretty much all middle you get the
origin and then the adventures go on and
on and on but nothing ever ends or truly
changes because then there wouldn't be a
franchise to earn more and more money
Avengers ends game though has set itself
up as an actual ending not for the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe of
course we all know there will be future
films on the MCU though exactly what
they'll be is another spoiler marvelous
holding on to until after endgame ends
but it certainly looks as though endgame
will provide some closure to the MCU as
we've known so far as the trailer
suggests major characters like Iron Man
Thor and Captain America form the
foundation of the MCU and one or more of
them are likely to see their stories
come to a conclusion and it's not just
them characters like Hawkeye Gamora
and the crews banner all have questions
to be answered and character arcs to
completes don't expect all your favorite
characters to get happy endings though
thanks in part to the recent acquisition
of Fox by parent company Disney Marvel
has a whole new wave of Heroes they can
feature in upcoming phasers like the
x-men and the Fantastic Four that gives
them the unusual luxury of being able to
afford to give a proper and final
farewell to some of their biggest
characters and franchises so far because
they don't have to worry about the box
office all they have to worry about is
making a good story that will satisfy
fans who have spent a decade of their
lives getting invested in the fate of
the Avengers and so far it sure looks as
though Marvel is going to make good on
just about all of their promises check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite Marvel heroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]